Messi llega y Volver al Fútbol Club
Barcelona y hay esperanza para los culés
esto al menos es lo que sale de esta
reunión entre Jorge Messi y el Joan la
Pauta el presidente del club una reunión
sorpresa donde la gente y padre del
futbolista se reunió con el presidente
de el Barça en su residencia aquí en
Barcelona y al salir de esta negociación
pues Jorge Messi preguntado por
periodistas congregados dijo
textualmente que a él y a su hijo les
encantaría volver al Barça pero también
dijo que depende todavía de un montón de
cosas estas declaraciones son algo más
optimistas que las que hizo Joan la
Pauta este fin de semana en un vídeo
amateur donde se le ve decía que estaba
difícil la situación Para volver el
crack argentino al club que le vio
crecer donde estuvo más de 20 años
porque pues el club azul gana Todavía
está en una situación complicada a nivel
financiero y está esperando el Ok de la
liga Aunque Fuentes del club azulgrana
dicen que llegarán pocos días después
haga falta una oferta oficial ya que ya
Messi tiene encima en la mesa dos más
una saudí y una de mi